so I'm going to take a picture so I
remember how many of you are here smile
like Sammy says my name is sherry Moore
I work in a Google brain team so today
I'll be giving a tutorial on tensor flow
first I'll talk up a little bit about
what tends to flow is and how it works
how we use it at Google and then the
important part is that I'm going to work
with you together to build a couple
models to solve the most classic machine
learning problems so Cal get your feet
beat for those of you from New Zealand
anybody from New Zealand so hopefully at
the end you'll be going home with all
the tools that you have to build all the
wonderful things that you have watched
today like all the image recognition the
training of different colors arts making
music so that's the goal so before I go
any further
has everybody installed tensorflow yay
brilliant thank you and I would like to
acknowledge so I know the link here says
Syrian but if you have Wolff g TF
tutorial is perfectly fine Wolff is
actually the my colleague who spent all
the time verifying installation and
every single platform so I would really
like to thank him thanks wolf if you're
watching and also I have my wonderful
product bus a product manager in the
audience somewhere so if you guys have
any requests for tensorflow
make sure that you go find him and tell
him why that tencel must support this
feature or exact somewhere all right so
there he is so with that we can move
forward to talk about tensor flow so
what exactly is tends to flow tensor
flow is a machine learning library that
we developed at Google and we
open-source the last November and ever
since then we have become the most most
popular machine learning library and get
help
how do we know because we have over
32,000 stars those of you who track
github you know how hard it is to get
rid of those acknowledgement and we also
have over 14,000 Forks and we have over
800 no 8,000 contributions from 400
developers 400 individual developers and
we designed this specifically for
machine learning however is your see
later because of its really flexible
dataflow infrastructure it makes it
really suitable for pretty much any
application that can fit into that model
basically if your model can be
asynchronous in fire on when data is
ready you can probably use tinder for it
originally we worked alongside with all
the researchers as a matter of fact I
was really fortunate when I joined the
team I sit right next to Alex the person
who invented alex net so that's how
closely we work together as we develop
tends to flow they would tell us no this
is how we use it yes when you do this it
makes our lives a lot easier and this is
why we believe that we have developed an
infrastructure that will work really
well for researchers and also being
Google we also always have in mind that
we would like to take from research to
prototyping to production in no time we
don't want to want you to write all the
code that's typically you're just
throwing away we want to write code that
can learn to cut and paste and save in
the file and privatize it immediately so
tensile is really designing with that in
mind so we will have way into your deep
learning school so can anybody tell me
if you want to build a neural net what
must you have what are the primitives
what are the yeah primitive I think is
the word I'm looking for
what must you have to build neural net
anybody what is in the neural net
This American history so in an Iran that
you have neurons that's right
so in and you need so all these neurons
what do they operate on what do all
these neurons do they process data data
and they operate on data and they do
something such as convolution matrix
multiplication max pooling average
pooling dropout whatever that is so
intensive flow all the data is held in
something called a tensor tensor is
nothing more than a multi-dimensional
array for those of you who are familiar
with numpy arrays it's very similar to
the ND array and the graph I think one
of the gentlemen earlier this morning
described there's this concept that the
graph which is a composition of all
these neurons that do different
functions and all these neurons are
connected to each other through the
inputs and outputs so as data become
available they would fire by firing men
they do what they're designed to do such
as doing matrix multiplication or
convolution and then they will produce
output for the next competition know
that's computer connected to the output
so by doing this so I don't know how
many of you can actually see this
animation yeah so this is to really
visualize how tensor flow works all
these nodes the Oval ones are
computation this rectangle ones are
staple nodes
so all these nodes they would generate
output or they take input and as soon as
all the inputs for a particular node are
available it would do its thing produce
output and then the tensor all the data
which are how in tensors will flow
through your network therefore tensor
flow yeah
so everybody's like wow this sounds like
magic
how does it work so who said is it sir
other car glasses any sufficiently was
the word any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic so that's what this is it's just
really awesome excuse me for a second I
know I want I want to get through this
as quickly as possible so we can
actually do the lab that you're all
dying to do so as any good
infrastructure so this is I want to give
you a little image of you know how we
design this in tensorflow just like any
well-designed infrastructure has to be
really modular because being module
allows you to innovate to upgrade to
improve to modify to do what everyone
with any piece as long as you keep the
api's consistent everybody can work in
parallel it's really empowering I think
that's one of the wonderful things
that's done at Google pretty much any
infrastructure at Google is really
modular they talked really about to to
each other all you need to maintain is
the API was stability so in this case we
have a front end I think you guys must
have seen some examples of how you
construct a graph so we have the
front-end libraries written your
favorite language and if C++ and Python
is no your favorite language feel free
to contribute we always welcome
contribution so you write you can show
your graph in your favorite language and
this graph will be sent to we call the
core a tensile execution system that's
your runtime and that's what you all
will be running today on your laptop
when you open your up your Python
notebook or should be the notebook so
the execution runtime depending on where
you are going to run this application it
will send the kernel to the
corresponding device so it could be a
CPU could be GPO could be your phone
could be CPU anybody knows what TPU is
brilliant very nice I was a stratum say
anybody knows what TPU is ever there's
like mmm translation so this is good so
just to highlight our portability today
you'll be running intensive roll in your
laptop we run it in our data center you
everybody can run on your iOS on your
iPhone your Android phone I would love
to see people putting it on Raspberry Pi
because can you imagine you can just
write on tensorflow application it could
be your security system because you know
somebody just stole my bike and my
security camera capture all this grainy
stuff that I cannot tell wouldn't it be
nice if you do machine learning on this
thing and they just start taking
high-resolution pictures you know when
when things are moving rather than
constantly capturing all this grainy
images which is totally useless
so I think the application literally
applications are limitless you know your
imagination is delivered so we talked
about what tensorflow is how it works
how do we use it at Google we use it
everywhere I think you have seen some of
the examples we use it to recognize
pictures this is actually done with
inception they can recognize after the
box one of thousand images you have to
retrain it if you wanted to recognize
they're all your relatives or you know
your pets it's not difficult and we I
have links you know for you to actually
if you want to train on your own images
it's really easy they should totally try
it will they be funny we go to your
relative your own 40 year reunion you
just go hi you know you who you I know
who you are you know just show off a
little it would be brilliant and we also
use it to do Google Voice Search this is
the one that's super awesome so how many
of you use smart reply have you ever
used smart reply yeah yeah this is
awesome especially for those of you who
are doing what you're not supposed to do
you know texting while driving your new
song email coming in and you can just
say oh yes I'll be there you know so
based on the statistics that
collected in February over 10% of the
other responses and on mobile is
actually done by our smart reply that's
or I believe if we have maybe exact can
collect some stats for me later maybe by
now you'll be like 80% it's actually
really funny at the very beginning when
we train it the first answer is always I
love you like that's probably it right
not the right answer we also play games
of you I'm sure have follow this the all
kinds of games that are being developed
it's really fun to watch if you watch it
literally come up with scenarios for you
to play as well it not only learns to
play the game but learns how to make a
game for you is fascinating and of
course art everything many of you have
done the Steve dream if we have time in
the end of the lab we can we can try
this so if you're super fast we can all
try to mix a Mart and all those what I
just talked about of course Google being
this wonderful generous company and
wants to share our knowledge so we have
actually published our models so if you
go to that link you'll find all these
inception and captioning language model
on the billion words the latest rest net
on c14 sequence the sequence which I
think Kwok will be talking about
tomorrow and in the world we have many
other high-level libraries so today my
lab the lab that we would do will be on
the core tensorflow api's but there are
tons of new higher level API such as
some of the mentioned cares and we have
slim we have pretty tensor we have TF
learn we have many libraries that's
developed on top of the court in several
api's then we encourage people to do so
if whatever is out there does not fit
your needs perfectly go for it develop
yo and we welcome the contribution we
published a lot of that here I might
have blurred some of the boundaries but
these are basically all the models and
libraries that we have produced and we
really love contribution if you have
developable
really cool model please do send to us
and we would you know we would showcase
your your work so that's the
introduction of tensorflow
how does everybody feel are you all
ready to get started
alright so okay before you bring up your
Python notebook I want to say what we
are going to do first okay so as I
mentioned there are two classic machine
learning problems everybody does one is
linear regression the other is
classification so we are going to do two
simple laps to cover those I do have a
lot of small exercises you can play with
I encourage you to play with it to be a
lot more comfortable so the first one is
a linear regression so I'm sure it has
been covered yeah in today's lectures
somebody must have covered linear
regression can you can anybody give me a
one-line summary what is the linear
regression problem anybody the
professors well if you don't know go
google it so I didn't know the the
audience you know when when semi asked
me to do this so I wanted to I wrote
this for one of the high schools so I
think it's doom kind of makes sense
right because all of us have done have
played this game at one point of our
lives like I you know if you if you tell
me a five or tell you ten and you try to
guess you know about the equation is we
must have all done this I think my
friends are still doing on Facebook
saying oh you know only Genius can solve
this kind of equation and then they
would be like yeah you I solved it I was
like my god if anybody you know I one
friend you guys if you click on another
one of those sir
but basically this is what we are trying
to do in the first lab so we will have a
mystery creation it's really simple it's
just a linear you know literally a line
and then we I will tell you that this is
you know the formula but I'm not going
to give you a weight W and B you know
all of you have learned by now W stands
for weight and bias B stands for bias
so the idea is that if you are given
enough samples if you're given enough x
and y values you should be able to make
a pretty good guess what W and B is so
that's what we are going to do so now
you can bring up your Jupiter notebook
if you don't have it up already
yeah everybody have it up yes
can I see show them hands everybody
those are yeah brilliant
alright so um for pretty much any models
these are going to come up over and over
again and just to make sure that you're
all paying attention I do have I asked
them if I was supposed to bring Shrek
and he said no but I do have a lot of
tensorflow stickers and I have all kinds
of little toys so later I'm going to ask
this question whoever can answer will
get some mystery present so really pay
attention okay so pretty much with it
whenever you build any model there are I
would say four things that you need you
need input you need data so you're going
to see in both labs we're going to be
defining some data you're going to be
built building an inference graph I
think in other lectures is also called a
forward graph to the point that it
produces logits or the logistic outputs
and then you're going to have a training
training operations which is where you
would define a loss an optimizer and I
think that's pretty much it hanging and
there's the fourth thing yeah and then
you will basically run the graph so the
three important things okay you'll
always have your data your inference
graph
you always have to define your laws and
your optimizer and the training is
basically to minimize your loss so I'm
going to be asking that later all right
so now we know what we're going to do so
you can go start go to that lab yeah
everybody have it so shift returned
we'll run the first one you said I have
no idea what
happening here return again still
nothing however let's see what we are
producing here so you can also do the
same on your laptop you can uncomment
that plot you can say so you know what
kind of data you're generating so in
this case when he returned why are we
seeing this is your input data this is
when you try to make a guess when your
friend tell me oh you don't give me your
x and y so this is how you know when
your X is 0.2 you know your Y is 0.32
so this is basically your input data
yeah everybody following if at any point
you're kind of lost raise your hand and
your buddy
next you will be able to help you so now
it's all okay I want to say one more
thing so today the laughs are all on
really core tends to flow ap is the
reason I want to do that I know there
are a lot of people who will use carrots
use another thing that we have heavily
advertised which is contribute
contribute you've learned so I feel like
I'm giving you all the ingredients so
even though you could go to Whole Foods
and buy the packaged meal you know maybe
one day you don't like the way they cook
it so I'm giving you all your lobsters
your Kobe beef okay so that you can
actually assemble whatever you want to
build to yourself so this next one is
very key it's a very key concept here
you see variables so variable intensive
flow is how is corresponding to the
square any of you remember this slide
okay I'm going to switch quickly don't
freak out so actually I wanted you all
to commit this little graph to to your
memory because you'll be seeing this
over and over again and it makes a lot
more sense when you have this visual
representation so intensive flow the way
we hold all the data the ways and the
biases associated associated with your
network is using
something called variable it's a state
fold operation I'm going to switch back
okay so this is what we are doing in
Section 1.3 we are building those square
nodes in your network to hold these ways
and variables and they are the ones when
you train that's where their gradients
will be applied to so that they will
eventually resemble the target network
that you are trying to to train for so
now you have built it wonderful okay so
you can shift return do you see anything
nope so exactly we'll have rebuilt let's
uncomment and take a look so these are
called the variable objects so at the
bottom of the slide for this lab I have
a link which is our Google 3 dogs the
API Docs which is available in github I
think you should always have that up so
whenever you want to do something you
will know what kind of operations are
possible with this object for example I
can say here what's the name of this
oh it's called variable 6y so call
variable 6 oh it's because when I create
this variable I didn't give it a name so
I can say
Sherri's sure you wait I hope that's not
but so see now my variable is called
Sheree wait same thing with my so this
would be a good practice because late
later
cheery-bye is
well because I ran this so many times
every single time you run if you don't
restart that it's going to continue to
grow your current path so to avoid that
confusion let me restart it restart
ja I had the word sorry
so now so we have done built our input
build an inference graph now we can
actually build our training graph and as
you have all learned we need to define a
loss function we need to define an
optimizer I think it's also called
something else record regulator maybe
some other terms and your ultimate goal
is to minimize your loss so I'm not
going to do it here but you can do it at
your your leisure you can you know
income and all the these things that you
have created and see what they are and I
can tell you these are different
operations so that's how you actually
get to learn about the network that you
have built really well in the next line
I'm also not going to uncomment but you
should at one point this is how you
cannot you can see what you have built
so actually why don't do that because
this is really critical and as you debug
this will become so this is the network
that you have built they have names
different names they have inputs and
outputs they have attributes and this is
how we connect all these nodes together
this is your neural net so what you have
what you're seeing right now is your
neural net that you have just built yeah
everybody following so now the next step
now you're done right you build your
network you build all your training now
you can let's do some training so in
tensor flow do you remember in the
architecture that I showed you have the
front-end C++ and Python front-end you
use that to build your graphs and then
you send a graph to your runtime and
this is exactly what we're doing here
whenever you this is how we talk to the
runtime we create something called
session you get a handle to the session
and then when you say run you're
basically sending this session your
graph so this is different from the
other machine learning libraries I
forgot which one those are so
comparative your happens as you type
tensor flow is different you have to
construct your graph and then you'll
create session to talk to your runtime
so that it knows how to run on your
different devices that's a very
important concept
because people constantly compare and
it's just different okay so now you can
also commented to see what the initial
values are but we're not going to do
that we're just going to run it and now
we're going to train the data is not so
what do you think of the data did we
succeed in guessing is everybody
following what we're trying to do yeah
yes no so what was our job objective
before I started the lab what did I say
my objective was yes to guess the
mystery function so have we succeeded
it's really hard to tell all right so
now all of you can go to the end and
income in this part let's see how
successful we are
so the Greenline was what we have
initialized our weight and buyers - yeah
the blue dots were the initial value of
the target values and the red dots is
our trained value makes sense so how
successful are we great big success yeah
I would say so
so any questions any questions so far so
other things so everybody should play
with this you're not going to break it
this is a notebook Python notebook the
worst that happens is they're just they
okay clear all like what I just did and
change it so what can you play with
since today you learn all these concepts
about different loss motions different
optimizers all this crazy different
inputs different data so now you can
play with that how about instead of
let's pick one so instead of gradient
descent what are the other optimizers
how can you find out I guess that's a
better question if I want to know what
other optimizers are available in tensor
flow how can I find out very good yes
the github good Google 3 the G 3 doc
link with the AP is I'm going to switch
one more tab bear with me so this is
when you go there this is what you can
find you can find all that I mean make
it bigger so you can find all the
different optimizers so you can play
with that
so maybe gradient descent is not the
best optimizer you can use so you go
there and say why the other optimizers
and then you can learn a come here in
search optimizer oh you can say wow you
know I have added Delta a dag red Adam
I'm sure there are more a momentum so we
also welcome contribution if you don't
like any of these please do you know go
contribute write a new optimizer send a
pull request we would love to have it so
I would like to say this over and over
again we love
contribution is an open-source project
so keep that in mind we would love to
see your code or your models on github
so back to this one how is everybody
feeling this is too simple yeah should
we go wet just yes can I say that
oh is that right
he tapped to see all the other
optimizers human Oh brilliant
see I didn't even know that learn
something new every day let me go there
tap here oh yay so this is even easier
thank you clearly I don't program in
notebook as often as I should have
so this is where you can all the
wonderful things that you can do thank
you this is probably a little too low
level I think it has everything but
that's a very good tip thank you so
anything else you would like to see what
linear regression is too simple you guys
all want to register commend some digits
alright so that sounds like a consensus
to me so let's move if you just go to
the bottom you can say click on this one
so this is our M this model so before
you start the lab so once again more
return to do so we have all these
handwritten digits what does M this
stand for does anybody know what is M
does stand for
very good see somebody can Google very
good so it has a stencil I think makes
National Institute of Standards and
Technology something like that so they
have this giant collection of digits so
you know if you go to the post office
you already know that it's the trivial
to solve problem but I don't know if
they actually use machine learning but
our goal today is to build little never
using tensorflow
that can recognize these digits once
again we will not have all the answers
right so all we know is that the network
the input will give us a 1 and it will
say it's a 9 and then the IMP and then
we have the so-called ground truth and
then they will look at and say no you're
wrong and then we have to say ok fine
this is a difference we are going to
train the network that way so that's our
goal yeah everybody see the network on
the side so now we can go to the lab so
can anybody tell me why the three or
four things that's really important
whenever you build a network what's the
first one your data second one inference
graph third one your train graph and
with this slab I'm going to teach you a
little bit more they are like the rock
you know it like when you go to
restaurant I not only give you your
lobstery or your Kobe beef I'm also
going to give you a little rock so you
can cook it ok so in this lab I've also
teach some absolute absolutely critical
additional infrastructure pieces such as
how to save a checkpoint how to load
from a checkpoint and how do you
evaluate your network I think somebody
at one point asked how do you know the
network is enough you evaluated to see
if it's good enough so those are the
three new pieces of information that
I'll be teaching you and also I'll teach
you a really really useful concept is
called place holder that was requested
by all the researchers we didn't used to
have it but
they they all came to us and say when I
trained I want to be able to feed my
network any day that we want so that's a
really key concept that's really useful
for any practical training whenever you
start writing real training code I think
you that will come in handy so those are
the I think four concepts now that I
will introduce in this lab that's
slightly different from the previous on
how to save checkpoint how to go from
checkpoint how to run evaluation and how
to use placeholders I think the
placeholder is actually going to be the
first one so once again we have our
typical boilerplate stuff so that you
hit return you import a bunch of
libraries the second one this is just
for convenience I define a set of
constants some of them you can play with
such as the maximum number of steps
where you're going to save all your data
how big the batch sizes are but some
other things that you cannot change
because of the data that I am providing
you for example the amnesties any
questions so far
so now we'll read some data it's
everybody there in 2.3 I'm a 2.3 right
now so now I use if you don't have slash
temp it might be an issue but hopefully
you do if you don't have slash lim
change the directory directory name so
the next one is where we build inference
so can anybody is just glancing and tell
me what we're building what kind of
network how many layers am i building
I have two hidden layers you have all
learned hidden layers here today and I
also have a linear layer which will
produce logits that's correct so that's
what all the inference graphs will
always do they always construct and they
produce logistic outputs so once again
here you can uncomment it and see it
what kind of graph you have built once
you have done the whole tutorial by
yourself you can actually run tensor
board and you can actually load this
graph that you have saved and you can
visualize it like what I have shown in
the slide I didn't draw the slide by
hand it's actually produced by tensor
boards so you can see the connection of
all your notes so I feel that that
visual representation is really
important also it's very easy for you to
validate that you have indeed build a
graph that you thought sometimes people
call something repeatedly and they have
generated this check and they grab
they're like oh that wasn't what I meant
so being able to visualize it's really
important any questions so far see here
I have good habits I actually gave all
my variables names once again the hidden
layer one hidden layer two they all have
weights and biases weights and biases
etc so now we're going to build our
train graphs so here is actually here
there's no new concept once again you
define a loss function we once again
pick gradient descent as our optimizer
we added a global step variable that's
what we will use later when we save our
checkpoints so you actually know at
which point what checkpoint this
corresponds to otherwise if you'll
always save it to the same name then
later you know you said wow this this
result is so wonderful but how long did
it take you have no idea so that's a
training concept that we introduced it's
called global step basically how long
you have trained and we usually save
that with a chair point so you know
which chair point has the best
information yeah everybody is good
at 2.5 so now the next one is the
additional stuff that I just mentioned
oh that piece of rock that I'm giving
you now to cook yourself so one is the
place holder so we are going to define
two one two hold your image and the
other two hold your labels there we
build it this way so that we only need
to build a graph once and we will be
able to use it for both training
inference and evaluation later it's very
handy you don't have to do it this way
and one of the exercises I put in my
slides to try to do it differently but
this is a very handy way and get you
very far with minimum work so as I said
in the slides I know I don't have any
highlighters beam's but you see there it
says after you create your placeholders
I said add to collection and remember
this up and later we'll see how we're
going to recall this up and how we're
going to use it in the next one we're
going to call inference build our
inference is everybody following this
part okay and once again we remember our
logits and then we create our train up
and our los up just like with linear
regression just like with the linear
regression we're going to initialize all
variables and now at the bottom of this
cell that's the second new concept that
I'm introducing which is the saver this
is what you will use to do checkpoints
to save the states of your network so
that later you can evaluate it or if
your training was interrupted you can
know from a previous checkpoint and
continue training from there rather than
always we initialize all your variables
and start from scratch when your
training really big networks such as
Inception is absolutely critical because
when I I think when I first trained
inception it took probably six days and
then later when we have 50 replicas it
took still like stay of the Rs do two
and a half days you don't want to have
to start
from scratch every single time so yeah
everybody got that the placeholder and
the saver so now it's 2.7 we're going to
go to 2.7 hmm lots of code can anybody
tell me what it's trying to do so this
is an yes so it's trying to minimize
loss we can actually see this so I will
run it once okay where did I go okay
very fast it's done but what if I really
want to see what it's doing so python is
wonderful so I would like to actually
see did somebody show like how you know
your training is going wow they show the
loss going down going down low I think
my training is going really well so
we're going to do something similar
sorry so I'm going to create a variable
audio car losses which is just an array
so here I'm actually going to remember
it
pinned so am i collecting
man plot map la lip anybody remember
this is a plot let's try this whoa look
at that now do you see you're lost going
down so it's you train your loss
actually goes down so this is how when
you do large-scale training this is what
we typically do we have a gazillion of
this jobs running in the morning with
just glanced at it and we know which one
is doing really really well so of course
you know that that's just when you are
up for the typing that's a really really
handy tool but I'm going to show you
something even better
oh that's part of the exercise me and I
don't have it so it's one of the
exercise I also put the answers in the
backup slides that you guys are welcome
to cut and paste into a cell they can
actually run all all the evaluation sets
against your checkpoint so that you know
how well you're performing so you don't
have to rely on your eyes you know
cleansing or my loss is going down or
relying on validating a single image but
see this is how easy it is this is how
easy the prototype and you can learn it
very often our researchers would cut and
paste their collab code and put in a
file and and that's basically their
algorithm and they will publish that
with their paper they would send it to
our data scientists or production people
we would actually privatize some of
their research this this is how easy
literally from research to prototyping
to production really streamlined and you
can do it in no time so for those of you
who have run the step can you do an LS
in your data path wherever you'll save
to that wherever you declare your
trainer to be what do you see in there
checkpoints that's right that's the
that's the money that's after all this
work well the Oldham one during all this
training on all these gazillion machines
that's where all your ways your biases
are stored so that later you can you
know load this network up and do your
inception to recognize images to reply
to email to do art etc etc so that's
really critical but how do we use it
have no fear all right let's move on to
2.8 if you are not already there so can
somebody tell me what we're trying to do
first
that's right first we load the
checkpoint and you remember all the
things that we told them told our
program to remember the logits
and the image placeholder in the label
placeholder how are we going to use it
now we're going to feed in some images
from our evaluation and see what it
thinks so now if you hit return
what's the ground truth
5 what's our prediction 3 what's the
actual image could be 3 could be 5 you
know but so the machine is getting
pretty close why I would I would say
that's a 3 ok let's try a different
different one so you can hear return
again in the same cell ohai need to
somehow move this so what's the ground
truth this time
yeah I got it right so you can keep
hitting you know you can keep hitting
return and see you know how well it's
doing but instead of validating you know
instead of hitting return a hundred
times and count how many times I had
gotten it wrong as I said in one of the
exercises and I also put the answer in
the slide so you can cut and paste and
actually do a complete validation on the
whole validation set but what do you
think
I really so you can actually hand write
a different digit but the trick is that
a lot of people actually try there and
told me it doesn't seem to work so
remember in on the slide I said this is
what the machine sees this is where I
see s and this is more the machine sees
so in the end instead of set all the
numbers are between 0 and 1 I believe I
could be wrong but I believe it's
between 0 & 1 so if you just use a
random tool like your phone you write
the number and you upload it number one
the picture might be too big and need to
scale it down number two it might have a
different representation sometimes it's
from 0 to 255 and you need to scale it
you know to the range that M this that
how you have trained your network if you
train your network with those data and
then it should be able to recognize the
same set of data just like when we teach
a baby right if if you have never been
exposed to something you're not going to
be able to recognize it
just like with oriole one of our
colleagues caption was at that program a
while ago anytime when I see something
that it doesn't recognize have anybody
play with that captioning software is
super fun so you can take a picture and
say you know two people eating pizza or
you know dog surfing but any time it
sees something that has never been
trained on it would say men talking on
the cell phone so for a while we had a
lot of fun with it we would put a
watermelon on the post and they would
say men talking on the cell phone you
put a bunch of furniture in the room you
know with nothing and it was they men
talking on the cell phone so it was
really fun but just like with your
numbers if you have never trained it
with that style like if I write Chinese
characters here it's never going to
recognize it but this is pretty fun so
you can play with it you know you can
see how well see every time see so far
is 100 percent other than the first one
which I cannot tell either so what are
some of the exercises that we can do
here what do you want to do with this
lab it's too easy huh because I made it
so easy because
know that you guys are all experts but
now otherwise I would have done it much
harder now let me see what things we can
do so you can uncomment all the graphs
oh so here's one actually you already
see it so try this can you guys try
saving the checkpoints say every 100
steps and you're going to have a
gazillion but they're tiny tiny
checkpoints so it's okay and try to run
evaluation with a different checkpoint
and see what you get
do you know how to do that yeah
everybody not to do that so the idea is
that when you run the evaluation is in
the it's very similar so we typically
run training in the evaluation in
parallel or validation so us it trains
every so often say every half an hour
depending on the the depending on your
problem so with inception every ten
minutes we're also the run evaluation to
see how well our model is doing so if
our model gets to say 78.6% which I
believe is the state of the art we'll be
like ooh my mother's done training so
that's how that's why you want to save
checkpoints often and then you know
validate them often if you're done with
that already did you notice anything if
you try to load from a really already
checkpoint how is your how good is it
when it tries to identify the the digits
just take a wild guess
yeah very bad maybe whenever you every
other one is wrong but this M this is
such a small data set is very easy to
train and we have such a you know deep
network if you only have one layer or
maybe it won't get it right so another
exercise I think all these you can you
can do after the lecture after this
session is that really try to learn too
evaluation from scratch rather than
actually another part but run evaluation
on the complete validation set that's a
that's a really necessary skill to
develop as you build bigger models and
need to run validation so I think this
is the end of my my lab I do have bonus
laughs but I want to cover this first
the bottom line is that tensorflow is
really it's for machine learning is
really from research to prototyping to
production it's really designed for that
and I really hope everybody in the
audience can give it a try and if there
are any features that you find it
lacking that you would like to see
implemented either send us pour requests
we always welcome contribution I'll talk
to my wonderful product manager Zack
sitting over there he is taking requests
for features so with that yeah things
that have fun
Thank You Shari did we have time for
questions for those who actually tried
it see you so well done and everybody
feel like their experts are all ready to
go make arts now right right goes deep
dream cool if there are no questions I
hope there's one question I think
someone who's trying desperately hi my
name is peachy low and first of all
thank you for the for introducing
tensorflow and for designing it I have
two questions
so the first questions is I know the
tensorflow have C++ API right so let's
say if I use Kira's or any of the Python
front-end I train a model can I have
that sense of loss support adjust I can
pull out the C++ model of it and then
just use that yes you can so even if I
use for example Kira's custom layer that
I caught using Python I still can get
those things correct oh it's just a
front-end that's different how you
construct the graph nice but we are not
as complete on our C++ API designs for
example a lot of the training libraries
are not complete yes so but for the
simple models yes you can do well let's
say not the training but let's say if I
just want the testing part because I
don't need to do I mean the training I
was doing is we do have that already Oh
actually if you go to our website
there's a label images does CC I think
that's literally just loading from
SharePoint and run the inference in C
then that's all written in C++ so that's
a good example to follow
Oh a second one so another thing that I
noticed that you support almost
everything except windows everything
acceptable I mean I always Android have
no fear actually we are actively doing
that but when I first joined the team I
think there were 10 of us and we have to
do everything like before open sourcing
all of us were in the in the
in the conference from together we're
all riding dog we're fixing everything
so now we have more people that's like
the top of our list we would love to
support it so so I'm just curious
because I I mean when I look at the road
man I didn't see a clear timeline for
Windows but the thing I know they just
like the reason why you cannot support
Windows is because of basil basil
doesn't support Windows so let's say
theoretically well I mean what you think
just like I know basil they're just that
you will get window Phi at some someone
November that is why they say so once
Plato can run in Windows can I expect
wedges I could immediately do tens of
law do you foresee some other problem
maybe Zac would like to take that
question okay this so yeah let's talk
offline yeah sure thank you very much
sorry I great presentation yeah my name
is Yuri fish I have a question about
GPUs are they available right now for
testing and playing for non Google
employees are we I don't think so at the
moment and do you know when it might be
available in the Google well would you
like to take that one
I'm so glad we have a Prada boss here so
he can okay thank you nice to Tori I
have a question are there any like plans
to integrate tensorflow
with the like open-source framework like
my sauce and HDFS to make the distribute
tensorflow easy so there are definitely
plans we are also always actively
working on new features but we cannot
provide a solid timeline right now so
that we do have like like is you know we
do have plans we do have projects in
progress but we cannot commit on a
timeline so I cannot give you a time
saying yes by November you have
so thank you but if you have this type
of question I think Zac is the best
person to answer today oh hi I was
wondering um the sensor flow having
examples to load your own data of what
witch did um so the current example has
a m nest of data set are there examples
out there to load your own data set yes
yes definitely I think we have two ones
called the tencel flow poet I think that
one that example shows you how you can
know your own data set I think is there
another one Zack are you aware of
another one that might be a loading your
own data set I know we have retraining
model you know if you go to tensorflow
we have an example to do retraining
those you can download from anywhere so
in our example we just downloaded a
bunch of flowers so you can definitely
download whatever pictures that you want
to return thank you hello thank you for
your presentation I have a question
concerning the the training you can't
you can train using throw tensorflow
in any virtually any system like Android
and what about the model is do you
provide anything to move the model to
Android is there because I'm generally
you programming Java there and yes so
that's a beautiful thing you remember
the architecture that I showed yes you
build a model and they just send it to
the runtime it's the same model running
on any of the different platforms it can
be a laptop and Roy you have your own
specific format for the model or it's
Justin you build a model is just bunch
of matrix and matrix and values yeah is
there any special special format for
your model because I sometimes it will
it is big yes comparable I will not
recommend training the inception on your
phone because all the convolution is a
bad problem probably kill it ten times
over so definitely
so there will be that type of limitation
like I think you guys talked about the
number of parameters if it blows the
memory footprint on your phone it's just
not going to work and if the compute
like it special for convolution it uses
of other computers yes that's for
straining but what inference you can run
it anywhere okay thank you it's the same
model you just restore actually are
examples like label image that's our C++
version I think I also wrote one's
called classify images in Python that's
all so you can run it on your phone so
any of these you can write your own and
though the sharepoint and run it on your
phone as well so definitely I encourage
you to do that thank you
hi I have a question related to tens of
flow solving so I went through the the
online documentation and currently I
think it requires some coding in C++ and
then combined with Python is there only
going to be you know only Python
solution that's going to be provided or
is it always going to be you know I
think you need to do some first step you
need to create a module and then you
know it just imported into water I am
actually surprised to hear that because
I'm pretty sure that you can write the
model in just Python or just C++ you
don't have to write it in one way or the
other they might have a special exporter
tool at one point that was the case they
wrote their exporter in C++ I think
that's well probably what you were
talking about but you don't have to
build it in any specific way the model
is just you can write in whatever
language you like as long as it produces
that graph and that's all it needs so so
tender for serving the tutorial actually
if you go on the side it had yeah a
little steps actually okay so I will
look into that so maybe you can come
find me later and now I'll see what the
situations I do know that at one point
they were writing the exporter in C++
only but that should have changed by now
because we are doing another version of
the serving tensorflow serving and is
there any plan to you know provide
API is for other languages like you know
like MX night has something called MX
like J's and you know you mean that the
front-end front-end yeah yeah we have Co
I think we have Co we have some other
languages maybe as I can speak more to
it and once again if those languages on
our favorite please do contribute and if
you would like us to do it talk to Zach
and maybe he can put out you know maybe
I don't know because there's somebody
else for the Android you need Java for
nicely so I think that's going to help
out in integrating these models with us
yeah that's great great feedback will
definitely take note thank you thank you
I have a caution I'm having embedded GP
board TX 1 which is an ARM processor and
I really wanted to work with the
tensorflow but I got to know that it can
only run on x86 boards so when can we
expect the tensorflow can support ARM
processors we will have to get back to
you after I have consulted with my Prada
boss say when we can add that support
thank you sorry one last question thanks
for the presentation sherry I have a
question regarding D when you have the
model you want to run variants is it
possible to make an executable out of it
so we can drop it into a container or
run it separately from serving is that
that's something that you guys are
looking into just run the inference yeah
just have it as the time as a binary
yeah yeah you can definitely do that
right now you can yeah you can all use
you are always able to do that you mean
just save you man just save the you
won't what I mean is that if you can
package it into a single binary source
that you can just pass around yes yes we
actually do that today that's how the
label image works it's just it's only
individual binary okay
they actually converted all the chair
points into constants so it doesn't even
need to do this lo etc it just reads a
bunch of constants and runs it so it's
super fast
yep okay that's a thanks sherry again
we are going to take a short break of
ten minutes let me remind you for those
who haven't noticed yet but all the
slides of all the talks will be
available on the website so do not worry
they will be available at some point as
soon as we get them from the speakers oh
I forgot to ask my bonus question but in
any case I have a lot of tensorflow
stickers up here if you like one to put
proudly display your laptop come get it